[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGEI SOKOLENKO:
Hello and welcome.
My name is Sergei Sokolenko.
I am a product manager
at the Google Cloud.
And today with me, I
have George Hilios,
vice president of Two Sigma.
Talking to you about advancing
serverless data processing
in Cloud Dataflow by separating
state and compute storage.
But before we talk about
separating compute and sate
storage, I wanted
to do very quickly,
a historical
retrospective of how
the industry used to
process really largely data
sets in the past.
Imagine it's the
year 2000, and you
have a one petabyte large data
set that you want to process.
Who am I kidding?
In the year 2000, a
really large data set
was probably something
you measured in terabytes.
Well, still, you have
a terabyte of data.
And you want to process
it, and it's the year 2000.
So you'd probably use something
like this, an architecture,
something like this.
You would use a large
box with lots of CPU
and might be a
mainframe or a Unix box.
The storage would be provided
through a storage area network.
Then come 2004, new distributed
processing frameworks
were released.
And now, you would probably be
using a cluster of cheap Linux
nodes with storage actually
being part of that processing
node, so local storage.
Then as things moved
into the cloud,
you were still using these
clusters of Linux nodes.
But now, you would be using
network-attached storage
provided by the cloud provider.
In 2010, Google
published a white paper.
We called it the
Dremel paper, which
defined the new architecture
for processing really
large web-scale data sets.
And that architecture was
based on the following idea.
You would have a independent
highly-available cluster
of compute.
And you would have
highly-reliable storage
facilities.
In 2011, we launched
a product that
was based on this white
paper, on this concept.
We called it BigQuery.
And probably at this
conference, you've
heard about BigQuery many times.
Became a very
successful product.
So this is the
architecture of BigQuery.
It has the concepts described
in the Dremel white people.
It has a replicated
storage layer.
It has a highly-available
cluster of compute.
They're separate.
They're working together.
And they're connected through
a very fast petabyte scale
network.
But there's a component in this
architecture that was not part
of the original Dremel paper.
It's the [INAUDIBLE]
in-memory Shuffle [INAUDIBLE]..
Now you might ask yourself
what is this Shuffle?
Why was it added later
on when we actually
launched the product into
general availability?
So let's just quickly cover
the concept of Shuffle.
With Shuffle in data
processing, when
you have a big collection
of key value pairs,
and you want to do a grouping
or a join with another data set,
you need to sort these elements.
And when you have a single
node processing architecture,
you can easily sort
it more or less.
Either in-memory, you can sort
your data set in memory by key.
Or you have efficient
on-disk sorting algorithms.
Unfortunately, once
your data sets explode,
and you have to move
to a distributed
framework or a
distributed architecture
where you have lots of nodes, it
becomes somewhat more complex.
So your end goal is
to have everything
sorted by key and all
data elements associated
with a particular key co-located
on a particular worker node.
And what you end up
doing is you end up
shuffling or physically moving
data elements associated
with specific keys from
one box to another.
And that's the
process of shuffling.
Now as you can
imagine, this is a very
resource-intensive and
time-intensive process.
And as your data sets scale, it
becomes more and more complex.
That's why BigQuery
ended up building
a separate dedicated
component that
was just responsible for
shuffling big data sets.
And it became a
critical component
that connected the storage
as well as the compute nodes.
Now I am a product
manager of Dataflow,
and this is a
Dataflow-related question.
So you might ask yourself,
why am I spending so much time
talking about Shuffle?
We actually, in Dataflow
have the same problem.
We are providing the same data
transformations to customers.
We allow them to do groupings,
and joins, and aggregations,
and filtering, and projections.
So the problem set is
actually quite similar to what
BigQuery is dealing with.
Here's a screenshot of a
real Dataflow pipeline.
Let's just follow this pipeline
as it lives in our service.
Simplistically, it can be
presented by this diagram.
We have a couple
of data sources.
We have data transformations.
That's the green
things over there.
And then we have joined
some group [INAUDIBLE]..
That's a special kind of
a data transformation.
And finally, the data
ends up in a data sync.
So as you submit
this Dataflow job
to our service,
Cloud Dataflow, we
are going to create a cluster
of nodes to process it.
And these will be Compute
Engine virtual machines,
and we'll also use
persistent disk storage.
And they're going to start
reading from sources.
Once we have the green boxes,
the data transformations,
they're going to
run them on compute
and use some local storage.
And then when things enter the
joins and the group [INAUDIBLE]
they're actually
going to do a Shuffle.
And we're going to do the
Shuffle today using resistance
storage--
either the magnetic
type or SSD type,
whatever the customer specifies.
Ultimately, data gets
written into sync,
and we shut down the cluster.
And that's kind
of, in a nutshell,
how a Dataflow job works.
Now in Dataflow,
as I said, we are
dealing with the same kinds of
volume and scalability issues
that BigQuery is dealing with.
We have huge volumes of data
that customers want to process.
And so we ended up implementing
a very similar mechanism
for a distributed in-memory
Shuffle service in Dataflow.
And the service works like this.
You have your compute clusters
and data on your user code,
which you write either
in Java or Python.
Then we have the
Dataflow Shuffle.
And the Dataflow
Shuffle is deployed
for high-availability reasons
into multiple GCP regions.
So in each GCP region where a
Dataflow Shuffle is available,
we also have replication
and duplication
of Shuffle in every zone.
We have it deployed
in every zone.
We have a component we call
the outer zone placement.
And this component
decides, based
on the available capacity
and the job, which zone
it needs to be assigned to.
So we take care of
deciding which zone to run.
And then we have a
tier of components
which coordinate
the actual Shuffle
operation among themselves.
We have a Shuffle proxy,
which accepts the job,
and we have two file systems.
One is in-memory, and
the other one is on-disk.
And so if your job and
the available capacity
allows us to do a Shuffle
entirely in memory,
your data will never touch
disk and will quickly
join results to you.
But if your job is
size such as that we
have to cache some
of this data on disk,
we're going to transparently
move some of your data
from in-memory into disk
and then Shuffle it there.
For you, you don't have
to worry about anything.
We do transparent shuffling, and
we just return results to you.
So this entire architecture
requires no code changes
from users.
You can tell us just by
specifying a parameter
that you want to use
the Dataflow Shuffle.
And we're going to switch
from the PD-based Shuffle--
the one that we discussed
earlier in the talk--
to a service-based Shuffle
transparently to you.
Now today, I'm very
happy to announce
general availability of Dataflow
Shuffle in two GCP regions--
in US central one
and US west one.
Dataflow Shuffle has
been in beta for awhile.
Now, it's available
generally to all our users.
Let's quickly go through all the
benefits of Dataflow Shuffle.
The first benefit is
many of our customers
tell us that Shuffle is now
much faster than it used to be.
So if we take the same pipeline
and compare the execution times
of this pipeline using
magnetic disks, magnetic PD,
then SSD-PD, and the Dataflow
Shuffle-- the Shuffle service--
you're going to see that
the magnetic disks give you
maybe 55 minutes of duration
in your pipeline execution.
Now [INAUDIBLE]
pipeline, the one
that is using SSD-PDs,
persist in disks,
will run in
approximately 17 minutes.
The Dataflow Shuffle one will
actually run in 10 minutes.
These results are not always
applicable to every use case,
but many of our
customers are telling us
that's what they are seeing.
The other benefit
of Dataflow Shuffle
is that we are now able
to process and shuffle
much larger data sets.
And you're going
to see in a demo
the sizes of shuffles
we can now support.
If previously the untuned jobs--
the ones that used magnetic
disks--
were able to shuffle tens
of terabytes of data,
and jobs that used SSD-PDs
were able to shuffle up
to 50 terabytes of
data, now, we can push
into hundreds of terabytes.
So with this, I
wanted to show you
a demo that actually
runs a Shuffle job.
And here's how the
job looks like.
I have two inputs--
two GCS buckets, a data
set and GCS buckets.
And I'm going to read a 50
terabyte data set in each case,
in each of the inputs.
And I'm going to join them and
write them into a GCS bucket.
The code for this pipeline
is written in Scala
using a framework that one
of our customers developed.
It's called [INAUDIBLE].
Spotify are the original
developers of this framework.
And I like
[INAUDIBLE],, because it
allows me to very easily
define my pipelines.
The entire pipeline is these
10 to 15 lines of code.
For those of you who
might not see it,
let me just quickly
explain what it does.
In the main function,
I define my first input
and my second input.
And then I do a left outer join.
And I write the output to files.
That's all this pipeline does.
And let me switch to
the demonstration.
Before we switch
to demonstration,
you might ask me yourself,
how does the input work?
Here's a screenshot
of one of the files
that I will be joining.
It consists of three columns.
The first column is the key.
That's the key I
want to join on.
And it's just random
generated strings.
Then I have a record ID.
I have billions of
records in my data set.
And so this record
ID is pretty long.
It's a very long string.
And then I have the
payload, the value that I
want to associate with the key.
And so with this, let's
switch to the demonstration,
and let me run a few commands.
Great.
So I'm in bash, in terminal.
The first thing I
want to show you
is the contents of
my bucket from which
I will be reading files.
I've defined a bash
variable, input 50 TBs.
And this is the
bucket that contains
50 terabytes worth of files.
So I have 50,000
1-gigabyte large files
that have data with
random keys that I
will be joining together.
And just to show you that this
bucket really contains 50 TBs,
I ran a listing command.
And here's my proof it does
really contain 50 terabytes.
I'm not going to run
now, because if I ran it,
then listing 50,000 files will
actually take several minutes.
That's why I run it before.
Now my next command is the one
that will create the pipeline.
And I'm going to be using the
Scala build tool to quickly
execute from the command
line the command that
launches a Dataflow job.
And as you can see, what
I need to specify here
is, what is my input?
And both of the inputs will be
reading from the sync bucket,
the output bucket,
and the parameter
instruction, the
Dataflow service
to use the Shuffle service.
So I'm going to
run this command.
And so within a minute or two,
the code will be packaged.
All of the dependencies
will be deployed.
And I'm going to
initiate my job.
I'm going to give
it a few seconds.
Depending on the Wi-Fi
gods, if we're lucky,
it will be done quickly.
But in any case, I
also ran a Shuffle just
before the demo, a Shuffle
that processed 100 terabytes.
So here's my job.
Just to give you a few
data points about this job,
the job took 500 billion
elements in my data set.
It was about 51 terabytes.
In the second input, I had also
500 billion rows, another 51.
And then I joined them
in this operation.
In Dataflow, we call
joins co-group by keys.
And so it created 100, I
think, billion combinations
of these keys.
Some of the keys overlapped.
Some of them didn't.
And then I wrote
them out into files.
And I actually created 2.5.
trillion lines in my
output, 2.5 trillion,
almost one petabyte of outputs.
And this job took
about 7.5 hours.
And I was able to process
it with 10 lines of code.
Back to my slides, please.
So hopefully, I was
able to show you
that now it's very easy
to do large scale Shuffle
processing with Cloud Dataflow.
In addition to my
100 terabyte run,
I also ran a few
smaller jobs just
to show you the scalability
of this process.
So I did a four terabyte
run, a 20 terabyte run,
and the 100 terabyte run.
With 5x data
increased every time.
And the execution time
was pretty much linear,
which is what you want to have.
You don't want to have
a quadratic escalation
of your duration.
If you can achieve
linearity in execution time,
that's a very good result.
What you don't see
on this slide is
that the resources
that you consumed
during this execution, what we
call Shuffle data processed,
also scaled linearly.
If you're difference
in data is 2x,
you will only pay 2x
more for such a job.
It's another good
property of a service.
You are able to
scale both duration
as well as cost linearly
as your data processes.
Now we talked about
batch pipelines.
And hopefully, I
was able to show you
that in batch processing, being
able to do efficient shuffling
is important.
But what about
streaming processing?
Cloud Dataflow provides
both batch and streaming
capabilities.
And perhaps, in streaming
you also need Shuffle,
you might ask.
The answer is, yes,
it's also very important
to be able to do Shuffling
in streaming pipelines.
Because customers want to
join in group data elements.
But in addition to Shuffling,
in streaming pipeline,
the other thing
that is important
is that you need to be able
to efficiently store state.
State, as I said, relates
to windows, time windows
that you create when you're
on windowing aggregations
on streaming data.
So let's go through a
similar life of a pipeline
but for a streaming use case.
So this pipeline
leads from Pub/Sub,
does a windowing operation by
event time, does a grouping,
does a group by, does
an account aggregation,
and then writes into BigQuery.
Now the first thing to
note here is that when
you submit such a
job to Dataflow.
we're going to divide
it into three stages--
everything that comes
before the group by,
after the group by,
and the actual Shuffle step.
And once we divide it
into three portions,
we're going to start thinking,
how do we scale and distributed
this processing?
And our way of distributing
the incoming workload
to multiple workers
is by partitioning
your data set by key.
If your pipeline
already has a key
through maybe a group by
operation, we'll use that key.
If it doesn't have a group by,
then we'll auto-generate a key
and partition your
data that way.
So in this case, for example,
we have split the key spaces
for the pre-Shuffle and
the post-Shuffle operations
into ranges.
I'm going to show
you next what we are
going to do with these ranges.
Well, they're going to
assign them to workers.
So each key range
will be assigned
to an individual worker.
Once we've done the assignment
of key ranges to workers,
we are going to
persist the date,
make specific PD volumes
responsible for storage of data
as they relate to these
keys and key ranges.
When we have to scale a
pipeline in a streaming case,
we're actually going
to move an entire disk
from one worker to the other.
We're not going to
try to rearrange
key spaces and compress
them or reassign them.
We're going to take an entire
desk, an entire persistent disk
and reassign it
to another worker.
As you can imagine, it's another
time-intensive operation.
Streaming out of scaling has
been working for many customers
really well.
But in some cases,
it might end up
being a little bit
sluggish because we
have to reassign disks.
Now we talked about
group by, let's quickly
cover the windowing operation.
Here, it's important to
remember, in streaming,
there are two important
time dimensions
that you want to think about.
The first time dimension is
your business time dimension.
That's the event time.
This is when the
sales transaction
happened if you're dealing
with sales transactions.
Or it might be the time when
the user clicked on a link.
So it's the business time.
In our terminology,
we call it event time.
The other important time
dimension is processing time.
That's the time when
the business transaction
enters the processing pipeline.
And as you can
imagine, there could
be delays between
an event generated
by the source system
and this same event
entering a processing pipeline.
Now many customers
want to do, they
don't want to deal
with processing time
as a unit of analysis or
as a dimension of analysis.
They actually want to
deal with event time.
And they want to organize
the data elements
into windows of
either fixed duration,
or configurable duration,
or session-based windows.
But they want to group their
data elements by event time.
So with this in mind, what we
have to do on the Dataflow side
to allow such an
analytical processing,
we end up buffering
data elements on disk.
Because we have to store these
elements until the window
closes, and we can
initiate the processing
of elements in the window.
So in addition to
Shuffle, we also
store data elements
related to windows.
So we asked ourselves, can
we do something similar
for streaming pipelines, as
we did for the batch pipelines
with Shuffle?
And the answer is, yes.
I'm happy to
announce that today,
we made the streaming
engine available in beta
in two regions--
in US central 1
and Europe west 1.
Quickly about the
benefits of the streaming
engine and the architecture
of the streaming engine.
Your user code-- the code
that you write that represents
your business logic--
continues to run
on worker nodes.
But now, all the
streaming plumbing
that used to run in [INAUDIBLE]
and co-exist with your user
code that used to run
on the worker nodes,
it has been moved to a dedicated
service in Google's back end.
And it is responsible
for two things.
It's responsible for
windows state storage
as well as for
streaming Shuffle.
Your user code
communicates transparently.
You as a developer, you
don't have to think about it
or worry about it.
Very similarly to Dataflow
Shuffle in batch case,
you only have to provide
us with a parameter that
tells us that you want us
to use the streaming engine.
So your using code transparently
communicates with us back end.
And we do all the shuffling and
all the state storage for you.
The benefits are, we don't have
to move around disks anymore
if you want to scale.
So out of scaling and
streaming became much better.
We also can do maintenance
on our service much easier.
It doesn't interrupt you.
You can continue
running your pipeline.
We can do maintenance and
patches on the back end
without interrupting
you in most cases.
And we also consume less
resources on the worker nodes.
So now, your user code
that implements business
transactions and processes
your data element
has more CPU and
memory available to it.
So it can produce more
and crunch more data.
Here's an example that shows
you how streaming out of scaling
works together with
a streaming engine.
And what this diagram shows
you is a incoming stream
of data that ran
for about one hour
and ranged in bandwidth
and throughput between one
megabyte per second to
10 megabytes per second.
When I didn't use
the streaming engine,
Cloud Dataflow
scaled my workers.
And initially, it started
with three workers.
And then once
Dataflow sense there's
an increase in
incoming data, it's
scaled the number
of workers to 15.
It kept this number for awhile
and then scaled down, and then
waiting for another spike in
inputs and then scaled up.
Now if you compare this graph
to the graph with the streaming
engine, as you can see,
we used less workers.
And we were able to
scale down much faster.
Here are the two
graphs overlaid.
And it shows you quite nicely
how the streaming engine
is able to avoid scaling down
to high numbers of resources,
is using less
resources, and is also
more responsive to variations
in incoming data rate.
Of course, the best
stories about Dataflow
are told by our customers.
And so I'm very happy
to invite today,
George Hilios from Two Sigma,
who will be talking to you
about how Two Sigma is
using Cloud Dataflow.
[APPLAUSE]
GEORGE HILIOS: Thanks, Sergei.
So my name is George Hilios.
I'm a vice president
at Two Sigma.
Just a quick intro
into who Two Sigma is.
We are a Manhattan-based
hedge fund.
We take a scientific
approach to investing.
We hire scientists,
mathematicians, engineers,
the works.
Our mission is to find
value in the world's data.
So in particular, I had
our engineering group
that deals with
granular economic data.
I'm probably getting some
squints for most of you.
So let me explain what
that kind of means.
Here's an example.
The NOAA publishes a wealth
of information publicly.
There's weather forecast about
all regions of the United
States.
And so we have a big question--
can we correlate
weather activity
with regional economics to
predict financial outcomes?
These are the types of
questions data scientists
and engineers in my group ask.
And so this data tend
to be very large.
I actually jumped slides
a little too quickly.
Sorry.
The NOAA data compresses
about a terabyte or so.
But when you expand it and
look at all the rows of data,
this is into the
hundreds of terabytes.
So it's very, very large
to make sense of that.
So what do we do
with all this data?
We can do a lot of
things with this.
We can do geospatial analysis,
aggregate billions of rows
of data, terabytes
of data, ultimately,
to build alpha models.
So this type of work
is very lucrative.
It's very satisfying.
However, there is
a weakness there.
We get a lot of our data
from third-party vendors.
And so we're at risk
of bad vendor data
causing bad predictions.
So at Two Sigma, we take
data quality very seriously.
We build in anomaly
detections into all
of our pipelines
to guard ourself
against these bad outcomes.
Now when you're dealing
with data at this scale,
we have to build very
complex, high-scale systems
to detect these anomalies and
protect us and our investors.
And so this is where
Dataflow enters.
We really don't want to be
in the business of building
infrastructure.
We'd like to focus our energy on
business logic, things nuanced
to particular vendors
and the types of quirks
they threw our way.
But also, we're not a
particularly large team.
We don't have the
resources Google
tends to throw at these
infrastructure-type problems.
So can a team of
10 to 20 engineers
deal with 100, 200 terabyte data
sets without batting an eye?
Let me take a quick
little sidebar here.
How many of you know
what RFC-4180 is?
I'll be surprised to
see any hands out there.
I do, and this is the
format for CSV files.
These are comma
separated values.
It's the bread and
butter in the industry
for how files are distributed.
Unfortunately,
our vendors do not
tend to know what that RFC is.
Let me show you an example
of what that really entails.
And these are real examples.
Obviously, change for
presentation purposes.
So that comma, is that
separating two numbers,
or is that 15,600?
In this case, it
was actually 15,600.
Good luck to the pipeline
understanding that.
Within the same file, dates
represented in different ways.
Here is a new line character.
Is that a separate
row, or is that
the same string that happens
to have a new line in it.
A lot of these
vendors get their data
from third-party
sources to them,
and they're just
passing it along.
So if it's unescaped
and unquoted,
any off-the-shelf CSV
parser will choke on this.
And here's another one.
We've noticed that as the
days and months go by,
vendors decide to
expose new fields to us,
so the schema changes.
So imagine you're
a data engineer.
You're writing a pipeline.
And you have your code
for doing aggregation.
Do you have a line, a
conditional in there
that says, if date is
less than January 1, 2016,
I only expect four rows?
All your pipelines
would be littered
with this vendor-specific logic.
And it gets very
unwieldy very quickly.
So we wanted to use
this opportunity
with a tool like Dataflow to
eliminate this problem entirely
and get in front of it.
So let me show you an example
of what that looks like.
We built some tooling, which
we called the normalizer--
very creative naming we used--
on top of Dataflow.
And the very first
step up here really
involves taking the
list of files and a JSON
file we call the
schema as input.
I'll go into details of
what that schema file looks
like in the next slide.
But it's things like, the
first field has this name,
and it has this type-like
string or integer.
It has hooks for Python
user-defined functions
for doing custom
things, et cetera.
In this second step, we
implemented a custom file
source.
It takes a file
as input from GCS,
and it turns it into
a PCollection, which
is a Apache beam slash
Dataflow concept, a PCollection
of generic type, which is an
Avro object that has a schema.
Again, we want to
use open source
where possible to
leverage the innovations
and the contributions of
the broader community.
So we turn everything
into an object of a type.
And much later in the
pipeline, we split.
The stuff that
goes one direction
are all the rows
that we successfully
parsed, that we applied our
logic to normalize and put
everything to a schema.
And we use the same
Spotify library
Sergei mentioned earlier, CO,
to save it as a parquet file.
There is another
functionality in there
that I particularly appreciate.
It's that you can say,
I want 5 million rows
in every single parquet
file, which for those you
have done Spark, that is
actually kind of a hard thing
to do generally.
So when we output our
parquet files and process
them downstream, with
all the files being
very evenly distributed,
you make much better use
of your resources.
The other output I
want to call out,
because this is the hard-earned
experience that our data
engineering team has
built up over time.
We output an extra file that
includes summary statistics.
I'll also show an
example of this-- things
like the total number of
rows, the number of error rows
that we encountered, and so on.
And even more importantly,
say you're on support,
you get paged in the
middle of the night,
and there's a failure,
there's a spike in errors.
You'd like to have a
file you go to that
contains all of the rows that
you saw that were invalid.
Maybe the vendor got bored
and wanted to throw a new cork
your way.
I'm laughing because it's true.
And finally, I'm
super-proud to announce
that a partnership
between us and Google,
we really wanted to get parquet
loading directly into BigQuery.
And Google pulled
through big time here.
So we not only can produce
these parquet files,
but we can load
them to BigQuery.
So imagine having all your
raw vendor data in BigQuery
to do your research
on, to investigate
failures, et cetera.
And then if your aggregation
is simple or SQL-based,
you can just let the Google
infrastructure handle it
for you.
Furthermore, since these are
all open source technologies--
parquet, et cetera--
the data are small.
You can feed it
into [INAUDIBLE]..
If the data are big and nuanced,
you can' feed it to Spark.
We have one thing up front
that handles all of this.
It's a big deal for us.
So here's an example of a scheme
of file I talked about earlier.
There's a few
different types here.
That first one is a date time
in a very standard format--
an integer containing
the number of seconds
since Unix Epoch,
January 1, 1970, and very
standard convention here.
Way of a string--
we have a string hash that
takes its input another column.
We found that if your primary
key or your foreign key
is a string, that's
very compute-intensive
to do joins or group bys on.
And so with our standard
upfront processing,
we can hash a string as input
and add a new column there.
So when it gets
loaded to BigQuery,
we have the hash as
well as the source.
And then when we
process in Spark,
those groups are very fast.
And finally, [INAUDIBLE].
Some fields are
optional, and we want
to make it clear which one
should be treated as failures.
So here's an example
of our output--
the summary file.
I'm super-proud of
the work the team did.
Because this particular
vendor gave us over a trillion
rows of data.
And this is one of our
days worth of delivery.
We were successfully able to
parse 916 million records.
And we did this in a matter
of hours on Dataflow.
It scaled very linearly.
There's 185 parquet files.
You can kind of see
behind the circle,
they're very evenly-sized.
This is great for
Spark processing.
And the errors rows
is 0, because we
had no failures that day--
very powerful.
So let's tie this all together.
We have the data
from the vendor.
They give it to us FTPS,
3GCS, carrier pigeon,
whatever they want to do.
We first store it in GCS and
then process it in Dataflow.
This is where we do
our normalization,
turn it into parquet, and
output our summary statistics.
We then run our
ingestion checks.
Like I mentioned
earlier, we care deeply
about data quality in Two Sigma.
So we do things like fail if we
have a spike or a sharp decline
in the number of rows processed
or the number of errors
encountered.
Ideally, we have zero errors.
But sometimes, if you're
processing a billion rows,
you sort of shrug
at five failed rows.
That's just the reality
of the situation.
And last but not least,
we load to BigQuery
for analysis, research,
and further processing.
So I do want to highlight some
of the high-level benefits we
get here.
A small team like
ours can process
a ton of data with
very little effort.
And that trillion row data set
example I told you earlier,
we tried it in Spark previously.
And it took 1,000
workers two weeks
to crank through everything.
And this is a pretty
simple algorithm,
just parsing strings and
turning them into parquet.
In Dataflow, we did the whole
data set in one to two days.
One other benefit is
we don't have to manage
any of the infrastructure.
We just write our beam
pipeline and send it to Google.
And there's one more thing
I want to highlight there.
Sergei talked earlier
about Cloud Shuffle.
We found we should
just turn it on.
So either the data
set is small enough
to where Shuffle
is not invoked--
you can see on the
UI, there's a number
of bytes shuffled-- if
this number is small,
you don't really pay
much of anything for it.
But when that number is big,
and your data set is very large,
we've seen pipelines
take much less time
to run, which saves you on
compute and storage costs.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEI SOKOLENKO: But
let's wrap this up.
Hopefully, you were
able to see how
having a separate distributed
in-memory processing
mechanism for Shuffle improves
the efficiency of separating
compute from storage.
That was key for both batch
and streaming pipelines.
We have a new service
available for you today,
Dataflow Shuffle--
a new component, sorry,
not a new service.
We are not launching
a new service.
So for batch pipelines,
we have a new option
for you, Dataflow
Shuffle, that makes
your pipelines run faster.
And you are now able to
process much larger data sets
and shuffle much
larger data sets.
For the streaming pipelines,
we have the streaming engine.
And it improves the scalability
of your streaming pipelines.
Both of these features are now
available in two GCP regions--
in US central one,
and Europe west one.
Thank you very much.
And we will be happy
to take questions
either over microphone or
later on after the session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]